TIMOTHY JORDAN: Let's talk
about sharing contacts.
Now, the user will see these if,
say for example, they take
an image, tap on that image,
they'll see a Share menu item.
Tap on that Share menu item and
then there's a list of all
their sharing contacts.
And they look a little
bit like this.
Now these sharing contacts might
be their Google+ circles
for friends or family.
But they can also be something
that you add.
That means that the user could
share an image or a video that
they take on Glass directly
with your service.
Now, to make your service
available as a sharing
contact, you're going to want to
insert it into the contacts
collection.
This is similar to the timeline
collection, except
you're going to be inserting
a contact.
Now you need to provide just a
little bit of information, for
example, the ID, the display
name that you want presented
to the user, and a image to show
the user along with that
sharing contact.